I can tell that you're a movie and and
classic comedy fan because I I got to
see your movie Fool's Paradise and I
know it's coming out May 12th May 12th
okay only in theaters only in theaters
as it should be it's time it's time for
America to join again finally in the
cathedral that is a theater
um better than a real Cathedral because
there's none of that God talk or we
could yeah yeah
we could do some God talk before the
movie if you'd like if you like of
course it's all up to what you want to
do praise the Lord yeah
get your feet off the seat turn off your
phone
um
but I saw your movie Fool's Paradise and
I it it I really loved it I really love
your film and I love you in it and you
wrote this movie and you directed it
it's very sweet
um you guys haven't seen it yet because
I just got this Advanced uh copy that I
watched but it is very much
uh evocative to me of chaplain Buster
Keaton it's it's got a real sweetness to
it your character is
you're doing that same thing a chaplain
did uh out of necessity and then Harpo
Marx did which is you're not saying a
word
um and you're very expressive and you
really are uh
playing this person who is picked up by
the Hollywood Machine and um you're at
the very center of it and you're very
passive it's it's a little bit like
being there and being there I think was
my initial okay could I make a movie
like being there no one's going to do
that anymore I guess I'll just do it
myself and um
and then when I realized it's not
totally working I said okay can I
combine it with Broadway Danny Rose
where I have this sort of sad Sac guy uh
and that only in then was I able to sort
of land the plane your character is so
content in his own I will say one thing
he's so content in his own space that at
one point he's at a Hollywood party and
he doesn't say anything he's very much a
you know chaplain-ass kind of character
and he fall he get he falls into the
pool accidentally and can't swim and he
sinks to the bottom and his hat just
settles on his head and he's just
sitting at the bottom of the pool making
no effort and I thought this is such a
great example of how little this
character wants or needs and how passive
he is and you're just sitting there when
another character comes in and and and
and and saves you but had that character
not come in you would have stayed until
the movie would have ended there
which could have been an interesting
film just too short yeah but uh yeah
yeah I did an extremely passive
character and then you know there's some
justification which is that he's you
know we meet him in a mental institution
and the the idea is that he suffered
some sort of trauma and we don't know
what
he has almost like the mind of a child
and uh you know there's another doctor
there who says well you know if we give
him enough sort of exposure therapy
um and maybe if he has a meaningful
connection with another person he can
sort of Break Free from this uh sort of
regressive psychosis that he's in uh but
it's gonna be a lot of work and it's
gonna be a lot of effort a lot of time
and the other doctor says okay well
what's our first course of action and
the guy says well the state's not going
to pay for any of that so we're going to
put his ass in the first bus downtown
you're you're parodying Hollywood and
and but but also old Hollywood because
there's so many elements of the film
it's it's a mishmash of
um the Hollywood you're making fun of
they're making pictures and they're
making them almost the way they did in
the 30s but it takes place in current
times yeah sort of a heightened thing
yeah it's really fun where I thought
okay I could just set it now
but in some ways now is
not enough to satirize Hollywood can I
make it almost feel as though it's
satirizing Hollywood Through the Ages
yeah
um there's also a great part where your
character is invited on a talk show and
uh and it's you've made a generic talk
show and of course uh I'm watching it as
me and I'm watching these two uh idiots
laughing like hyenas that bring you out
and just find everything funny and
there's part of me that thought yeah
that's kind of
[Laughter]
I would love it no no but it's it's also
it's just it's it's uh it's parodying
every type of show like that so it's not
specific but it was really
um that part was really making me howl
because it's so over the top it's a good
performance by uh Jimmy Simpson
yeah yeah
um yeah I think initially I wanted to
see if I could go on a few talk shows
and and shoot it like that and then
ultimately I felt as though
stylistically would take you out and
then it would take you out of the movie
to have like a real world uh person
going back and forth between these
fictional characters also I mean a lot
of movies do that where the character
you know I taped a number in my day and
then you see it all the time and I
always thought it was something I never
loved doing which was when the character
and the sh in the movie has it briefly
stops off at a talk show and I'm there
saying so you mean to say that they
think there could be life on another
planet you know and then it shows up in
the movie theater and it just always
felt a little lame whereas creating a
fake talk show I thought was much
funnier oh thank you uh it it was
apparently it's it's trickier to make a
talk show than you would think because
there's no idea
I need to make a fake one I'd make a
fake one yeah because the sets are big
and the audience is big and I didn't
have the time or the budget to do that
so it's actually only a curtain and uh
and then the stage itself right there is
no audience there just spoiler alert
yeah
that's right well I'm a huge fan and I I
love your approach which is uh you're
trying to make people laugh it's
interesting when you take it back to its
core you know have some type people say
like what are you are you a satirist are
you a humorist and I think if you really
take it down to the core I think I might
be a clown and that might just be the
simplest way to put it and then you can
dress it up and if someone at the New
York Times likes you they call you
something else it sounds a little
fancier but at the core I'm still it's
the same impulse that I was using on a
playground in Brookline Mass in 1974.
yeah
um so you got kids to laugh do you do
you ever feel challenged by it as if um
I I often think okay am I going
am I making too many jokes are there too
many jokes within this movie do I have
to be more serious do I I mean there are
heartfelt moments in the movie but I
also undercut it frequently yeah no I
think it's really well paced I that was
my feeling is that it's really well
paced and yeah I think um uh
uh yes there are times where I look at
stuff I've done and we're in edit and
I'm just like shut up I mean I'm saying
it to myself I'm like shut up right
there's too much too many jokes too many
jokes and you're you know let's just and
and really Sometimes the best things
happen during Quiet Moments which took
me uh
you know a while to realize uh
unfortunately I realized it I think
fairly early on but and that that
sometimes saying very little and letting
someone else talk and just reacting to
them naturally is much funnier than
anything I'm going to come up with I did
a whole movie of that yeah yeah exactly
well exactly yeah
um
I find like when I'm writing something
you know I wrote another movie in the
time that I was sort of in the edit room
on this and I was passing it to some
friends and they were saying you know
like um
you should make it less funny
and uh you know because they like the
story and they said you get more serious
and I know that's the right direction
and I'll sit with it and I'll do it but
my first instinct always is just don't
people want to sit in a theater and just
laugh and laugh and laugh and laugh but
sometimes to get them to laugh you have
to pull a few jokes out so that the last
land right no it's true I I think that's
true what I don't want to do is make
people think
you don't I really don't
because I don't know I've heard that
before people like you know not only did
he make you laugh he made you think and
I go yeah lose that second part yeah
lose that part I want people to be
Dumber after they've seen my world yeah
I think I do too I think I do too well
this is an absolute Joy Charlie as I
said uh coming you know just I'm looking
forward to talking to you and it's been
a little while and I love that you're
doing this work I mean uh Fool's
Paradise is coming out Mar uh sorry May
May 12th May 12th and uh also uh you're
in the biggest movie in the world
true right now true uh it just made what
did it make it made eight billion
dollars eight billion of those little
coins that Mario hits
bashed into eight billion bricks their
hands are just bloody
uh yeah the Super Mario Brothers movie
uh that is uh congratulations thanks
that's uh crazy it's been a crazy ride
just um as long as you have a piece of
the merchandising you should be fine bad
news pal
I got some bad news for you yeah yeah
they paid me with uh with video game
coins
yeah but they make such a fun sound
that's how they got me that's how they
got they got uh well Charlie continued
success as if uh as if you needed it but
uh you will have it and uh you deserve
it so thank you for being here well
thank you I'm really I mean that you
like the movie because I do feel like
you're my target audience which is to
say like oh I'm like uh I want like a
Conan O'Brien to like this because if if
the if the top of the comedy guys like
it then I mean then it's up to uh the
standard that I hope it would be that is
really nice
back at you so thank you